Hi, my name is David Brown, and this is a reading writing class.
Hello, welcome. How are you?
Hi, nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you too. My name is David. What's your name?
My name is Francesco. Pleasure to meet you, David.
Nice to meet you, Francesco. Welcome.
I see that you selected a lesson about Walt Whitman and his famous poem,
Oh, captain, my captain, a reading and writing class. Is that right?
Yes, that is correct.
Okay, great.
So I'll tell you a little bit about Abraham Lincoln.
You've probably heard of honest Abe before he was the 16th US president.
He was assassinated in 1865.
You might compare him to another famous leader. Do you know who this guy is?
Yes, Francisco Morazán.
Francisco Morazán. Okay, so they're not the same, but they are very popular presidents, right?
Correct. Yes.
So this question for us is what makes a good leader?
Take a minute to think about it, and then you can share with me and talk about this.
What makes a good leader in your opinion?
Okay.
Do you want me to write it down or can I just start?
Yeah, you can.
I think it's not only someone that inspires, but also knows when to take action.
Okay.
Alright, agreed. Somebody with initiative, right?
Yes, absolutely.
I think both of these leaders were leaders who inspired others and took a great initiative.
I would agree.
Both of them were involved with some great liberal reforms as well.
Alright, so we have a list of things that can help us to improve our English in particular reading and writing and speaking too since we'll be having a conversation throughout the entire lesson.
These are our class objectives.
Can you read the class objectives starting with this one here?
Yes, identify and explain the historical context of O-Captain, My Captain.
Define key vocabulary.
For example,
?legy,
keel, rack,
or is it
elegy.
And identify and extend it metaphor within the poem.
Analyze the extended metaphor, explaining what the captain, ship, fearful trip and prize represent.
Discuss the tone of the poem as it relates to grief and admiration.
And express understanding of the poem through discussion and written responses.
Okay.
Oh, and connect the poem's themes of loss, leadership, and national strategy to broader concepts of freedom.
Is it a freedom?
Like freedom.
Yeah.
Oh, like freedom.
Alright, so we have a lot that we can do.
We might not have time to do all of this, but certainly there is a lot to digest about this poem.
And well, well, Whitman and historical context here.
The vocabulary can be a little bit antiquated because it's, it was written in 1865 right after the assassination of Abraham Lincoln.
So I just want you to keep that in mind as we read this.
There's a context to this poem.
And maybe it's talking about something a little deeper.
So when we say extended metaphor, you know, a metaphor is when A is B.
But an extended metaphor is when maybe a whole paragraph or text is standing for something.
Okay.
So some historical context here.
But first here, what do you know about the American Civil War or Abraham Lincoln?
Oh, I know, I know the nickname honest Abe.
(The) American Civil War was specifically regarding slavery.
If I'm not mistaken, correct?
Yes.
North and the South.
And then Abraham Lincoln.
Well, you said the 16th president, but I think there's something.
I think there was a very important decision he took and I can't quite remember it.
Something that he's really known about.
The emancipation proclamation.
Yeah.
All right.
Excellent.
So you know some about the American Civil War in the context of this poem.
How important this was the Civil War in the United States.
Didn't just affect the United States had a cascade effect to other countries.
And really changed a lot of attitudes.
And it wasn't over at the end of the Civil War.
And it's still not over.
Really, we still fight with inequality.
We still fight with issues related to slavery around the world.
And this question about what it really means to be free.
And it's still an uphill battle.
So we what Whitman wrote, oh, captain, my captain in 1865 shortly after two major events here.
Can you read this part for us?
Of course, the end of the Civil War, which lasted from 1861 to 1865.
A rural conflict that divided the nation.
And the assassination of President Abraham Abraham Lincoln in April 1865 just days after the Confederates surrender.
Lincoln was seen by many as the captain who had steered the nation.
the ship... through the fearful trip of the war.
So we see an example of a metaphor already the nation as the ship he steered it he was the captain.
in this poem that we're going to read.
So that we have another colored picture of Abraham Lincoln.
I just think it's cool that they can put color to old pictures now.
And it makes it look real.
And a scene from something that you would have seen in the newspaper.
So Abraham Lincoln was in a theater when he was shot and assassinated.
All right.
So here we have some terms that we need to know.
And you might hesitate with some of these vocabulary words.
They're a little difficult.
So we have lyric, elegy, metaphor and extended metaphor.
Lyric poetry is poetry that expresses personal emotions or feelings.
It's typically spoken in the first person.
So the poem that we're about to read is lyric poetry.
And this one, remember the pronunciation, elegy, could you read this for us?
Yes.
A poem of serious reflection, typically a lament for the dead.
Oh, captain, my captain is an elegy for Abraham Lincoln.
All right.
So we're talking about someone a captain who was killed.
And so the poem is really deep.
And it's a little dark in that sense.
You have to imagine the feeling at the end of a war.
The feeling at the end of the war is one of relief.
you could imagine, but also great sadness.
You can't bring back the lives that were lost.
You can't undo what was done.
What was done was done.
We have a metaphor, a figure of speech in which a word or phrase is applied.
So when one thing is another, and then this extension of that, the extended metaphor.
Could you read this one for us?
Yes.
A metaphor that is developed over several lines of writing or even throughout an entire work.
Great.
So here's the first reading.
I'll read this first one for you.
I want you to listen to the way that this sounds.
While follow eyes and steady keel.
The vessel grim and daring.
But oh, heart, heart, heart.
Oh, the bleeding drops of red.
Where on the deck, my captain lies, fallen cold and dead.
So we have this image of a ship with a keel.
So certain part of the ship, right?
The vessel grim and daring.
You see this dark ship entering.